speaking of racism the georgetown men's
basketball team
along with their coach the whole team
and their coach
took a knee before the national anthem
ahead of the
ncaa tournament game against colorado on
saturday
then they lost to colorado 96-73
good glad to hear that that's a silver
lining in this very
stormy story the kneeling for the flag
is a sign of disrespect i know some
disingenuous libs pretend that isn't the
case
but colin kaepernick who started the
whole protest said that
he says i am not going to stand up to
show pride in a flag for a country that
oppresses black people and people of
color
to me this is bigger than football so
he's saying when i stand up that shows
pride in my country and when we say
national pride what are we talking about
we're talking about
loyalty to the country we're talking
about patriotism we're talking about
love for the country
i'm not going to do that i'm going to
kneel down because i don't like this
country
and what these guys this georgetown
basketball team is doing is they're
saying i don't like my country
and i'm going to disrespect my country
now
if georgetown is receiving any taxpayer
money
they should lose that money the students
who did this
should be punished they should i hope be
kicked off the team
if not expelled from the school entirely
if the school administrators
do not punish these students for this
anti-american display the school should
lose its federal funding
and conservatives should be willing to
push for this sort of thing
we have fallen into the trap of
political correctness
whereby we either embrace their new
standards which are
disrespect the flag deny biological sex
deny this deny that
or we give up standards altogether and
we say well
free speech academic freedom whatever
first of all the modern conservative
movement began when bill buckley called
academic freedom a hoax
said it was a superstition in god and
man at yale
but moreover there is a thought that
stops thought okay we have to have
standards here
it is better to love our country than to
hate our country and if you hate your
country long enough you're not going to
have a country anymore so we need to
encourage people to love their country
we all did that in this country not not
even just conservatives but even
liberals did that in this country for a
long time
now we're pretending we're not allowed
to say that there's nothing hypocritical
about preferring the good and
discouraging evil and bad things
it's perfectly ordinary it's what every
political regime does
okay that's what conservatives need to
get more comfortable saying
and you're seeing some bubbling up of
this
when desantis says what he said about
vaccine passports
when president trump and in his
presidency
said we need to stand for things we need
to make america great again you know we
got to like we got to love our
communities we need
we want good things we want to go we
want to hug that american flag right
and this would also happen to be the
thesis of my book speechless
that i think is the future that is the
if if conservatism is to have a future
the country's gonna have a future that
that is gonna be the future otherwise
we're just giving up
and rolling over to the left in crisis
after crisis
after crisis if you enjoyed that video
be sure to hit the subscribe button so
everyone waiting through the wasteland
of youtube
knows that we've got the absolute top
content
out there
[Music]
[Music]